he's an actor comedian all-around good
guy Adam Sandler and fritzy goes to uh
you know 30 years ago today sandman
joined Saturday Night Live and I go
was that a positive experience for him
like do we want to bring up something
like that it started well and Sandman
joins us now right where are you right
now okay what what do you why wouldn't
it be a possum it was great and I didn't
know this thirty years I think Fritz
he's making this up because it's June
and Saturday Night Live ain't on and you
so how did that happen
Fritzi I was looking at a on this date
in history type site and it said June
22nd 1990 Adam Sandler debuts on
Saturday live weather was either debut
or he was officially hired however you
want to read it that's what I don't
think so though because I got hired
midseason
I think my per season I only did like 11
shows oh you know what then just you
know go back to bed we'll call you in
November when it is 2:30 I just wanted
to make something up so that we can get
you were looking for a guest and now I
got it it's a metal Bayless now we don't
have anybody coming on - yeah you were
so convincing let me tell you though you
know what today is
maybe this is what it said its my
anniversary
but you haven't been married 30 years I
don't know what a 30 came in maybe maybe
30 years ago I said to summer day I'm
gonna get married
open happy Anniversary to my wife and
she could she had we're gonna have fun
what did you what really yeah she she
said it and we can do dude do what we
got to do tonight we're looking forward
to it and I'm keeping the sunglasses on
for her too I look disgusting right now
Danny
yeah what happened why with those that's
kind of Hollywood look swollen man you
don't need to see that I just woke up
let's see fritzy made it seem like this
good fun and and by the way who
who's the baby in the front you guys
zoomed in a little bit I saw a nice
little baby who had the baby Danny
somebody a listener sent on in baby yeah
yes Seton you have a question I have
maybe this is what Todd is is getting
mixed up on this is actually the one
year anniversary of Adam playing the
Hershey giant Center that he did that
last year
that might be what were but but if it
was 30 years I 3 and I started when I
was 23 so the 30 years ago honest and
now thing makes sense I just don't know
if it's June 22nd who happened how did
you how do you get discovered to get the
audition in Saturday Night Live that was
I was stand-up Dennis Miller was a great
man he said I was he thought I was
pretty funny he alerted SNL brass to
come see me and then me and Chris Rock
and a few other great comedians went to
Chicago and audition I just saw a story
with you and Chris Rock we're walking
along the beach in Malibu and they
described what you had on like it was
and I know you love the paparazzi when
they follow you like that but can you
explain why you and Chris Rock were
walking on the beach was it hand in hand
[Laughter]
no you and Chris Rock are walking along
the beach in Malibu
why yes okay so Chris is staying down
the street we we've rarely had moments
like this where we can see sit and not
work so we were so we called each other
up and said let's meet on the beach or
walk we've been taking walks together
and enjoying each other's company and we
didn't know someone who's but Chris did
look good in pants and I would look good
in a third that's slightly too small on
me comedians in flip-flops
taking walk such a new show Netflix is
going to greenlight that Sandman yes you
know by the way I was on the downhill
side so that bothers you doesn't it I
you know all the guys that you hang out
with I've never seen rock play
basketball can rock play at all by the
way Chris has been working out of
something he looks different he's got
like thicker arms he looks like he's
taking it serious I've never seen a rock
cared this much about his body I think
he got to an age where he said I want to
live and he's been eating eating better
and uh and hitting the gym he's got
muscles got triceps he's got biceps I
never saw this one but it's so I'm sure
it's Luke his hoop skills at jumping no
that's not true I've never seen rock
play and you've never talked about Chris
Rock's basketball he we're talking to
Adam Sandler something happened 30 years
ago we're not sure but Paul what what
Paul and I have here that you were hired
to be a writer in November of 1990 and
then a couple months later you made your
first appearance in and doesn't say the
exact date but spring of 91 does that
sound right and they said they're gonna
put me on air too and then I started
writing skits and then my first on air
was Tom Hanks show and I played I played
a man I think this is my first one if I
played at an Israeli guy on this operas
I got December 8 1990 Adam Sandler
appears in the Sabra sketch with Tom
Hanks Edie Brickell is a musical guest
wow that's amazing
yes I think that's true so it's got
nothing to do with June 22nd June 22nd
is my marriage we got married on June
22nd at Dick Clark's estate in Malibu
and that was pretty great who showed up
at your wedding Tom Petty came to the
Tampa
that night got in a car accident on the
PCH and came to my wedding to use the
phone also he didn't kill me your
wedding invite him I didn't want to put
pressure on Tom Petty to show up but
Rodney Dangerfield came to my wedding
and my father was unfortunate very sick
at my wedding he had cancer and rodney
showed up and my father was in the bill
we were hiding out together because he
was dealing with the chemo and all that
and my father came in
I mean Rodney came in and goes where's
the dying god so Tom Petty gets in a car
accident right down the street
he doesn't know that you live there he's
just seeking helps so he knocks on the
door I think you know was right by Dick
Clark's the place we rented and I think
he was just he was like oh I know Adam
so I'll go use get some help over there
I think you know and not he came in and
all my New Hampshire friends went
bananas and they're like he doesn't play
he didn't play you know who played that
day Leon Redbone nice did you get up on
stage too I say House of the Rising Sun
[Laughter]
yes do you remember it I don't remember
everything but it was it was back then
it was to the tune of grow grow old with
you from the wedding singer I wrote all
the words for Jackie yes I like the
wedding singer okay I like you that
person in the wedding singer like that
guy is a good guy
imagine if I was like him all day long
that's not possible for you oh my kids
my kids
how is Father's Day
was great thank you my they went nuts
there how was yours Danny
I didn't get any cards I'm get a present
well I got they loaded me up I'm
drinking out of something right now can
you see this Cup what's it say I can
sort of see it as a dad a shark and then
it says my two little kids I don't know
how that happened
they don't call me dad a shark but this
happened yesterday so I I like that but
they get my wife my wife got him two
little books and it says and it's like I
love my daddy because and they fill out
the words it was like a hundred pages of
things and literally everything dealt
with like my daddy taught me how to and
then a blank space every answer was like
to eat every we think was about how much
food I showed up over the years hey when
does the movie QB Halloween that we shot
last summer come out
yes you were excellent at funny make me
laugh a lot dandy and I think in October
or late September but probably October
for the Halloween of it all mental be
Netflix allowed there be
trick-or-treating then okay okay yeah
damn yeah will people be allowed to
trick-or-treat by that in October no
right yes yes all right with masks on
keep social distancing all right the
LeBron James project yes is that started
no I mean we don't can't make a movie
yet but it's it's it's been we've been
working on it putting it together I'm
gonna send you there's a draft in like a
week but it's a it's a real cool movie
and I'm uh things are kind of kind of
coming together it's just talking about
if you can actually shoot a movie right
now a full movie it's it's tough you
know we what role does LeBron play
LeBron's company and
Rod's company they both they had the
script and they and it's about a and
they and they brought me on there to be
part of it and it's about a scout for
the Sixers finds a finds a kid in Spain
and it's about bringing him over to the
just trying out for the NBA is like my
my life in his life together when are
you some what role do you playing
I'm the Scout I'm the Scout I'm in a pen
I'm in Spain and I see this kid playing
and I bring them bring them over and
it's it's really good
the movie is really good it's just about
it's just about if we can shoot it and
when we could shoot it it sucks it's
tough man it's I at one day I think I
think it's going and then the next day
I'm like are we better wait because you
know you don't want to put anybody in
danger so that's it my wife hasn't been
able to get through uncut gems because
she says it's too like the anxiety yeah
she that's it she can't do it
no it's so it's tough it's like during
the pandemic when people would say hey
I'm watching that could you put your
sunglasses on I mean you kind of its
kind of bothering me the way you look
today it's really got grocery grocer
over you do cosmetic surgery I've had
too many surgeries Sandman on just
keeping my body together that I don't
want to I don't want needles I don't
want I don't want any that stuff but if
you if you could pick one that would
just you wake up the next day and it's
better what would you do
I I don't know if just one would do it I
would I would if I could do anything I
would get Fritzi my kidney he doesn't
need it though
I do get a lot of kidney I have to take
like potassium citrate every morning to
keep the stones from forming I get the
ones that are staghorn calculi that they
actually have to surgically remove and
put a stent in your kazoo and not just
pass they're too big to pass they're
over seven millimeters and then they got
put on an operating table
brutal Richie you got to film that let
it go through the doctors they said it's
so big that they actually have to either
open up your back or go in and do some
kind of procedure to get it out and put
you out and actually operate on getting
this done it or break it up with some
kind of special device where they
blasted it's that long rubber tube that
they put in there that stent is meiotic
it's not it's not that long that to see
did we make your day Sandman aren't you
happy you got up for an anniversary that
really is not an anniversary other than
your wedding anniversary well my best to
Jackie and you how many years no no you
got to get that right I think 17 I
thought 2003 okay yeah but we're a
little loose on anniversaries as well on
our end so you know
33 coming up in August you know what you
guys should do or 33rd yeah when it
comes up in August no it's a great
anniversary movie and you get nudity we
get to see you in a trunk with no
clothes on
our briefs I would love to see the
outtakes of that did you show anything
that you I'm sure it was cold hey thanks
for joining us for that anniversary
yeah and send the script I want to read
that script I want to now are you gonna
tell me what part I play or do I just
find what part I want to play I love you
in the Jordan all over it Danny that was
so cool
that's a long time ago that was a good
run like that doubt my hair looked good
back then you look great today Thank You
Sandman and happy Anniversary thanks Ari
that's Adam Sandler it was an
anniversary today